salut c'est Nico Martel bienvenue dans
la cuisine de l'info pour un webinar
spécial consacré au métier de
journaliste youtubeur alors j'ai à côté
de moi Valentine Delattre qui est
journaliste qui est youtubeuse et
bonjour Voilà bonjour ralentine et qu'on
va vous présenter tout de suite Nordine
scientifiques diplômés d'un master en
biologie évolution elle a notamment
travaillé pour des magazines comme
Sciences et Avenir ou Sciences et Vie
juniors elle a également sa chaîne
Youtube science de comptoir où elle
parle de géologie et exprime une étrange
fascination pour les cailloux elle
participe également ovortex une chaîne
Youtube ou des vulgarisateurs
scientifiques vivant ensemble dans une
colocation elle anime aussi les lives
twitch scientifiques Darte et
participent à la chaîne info ou MiTo sur
Youtube avec les vidéos mytho-terror ou
elle décortique les fake news et un fox
scientifique les plus populaires elle
s'appelle donc Valentine Delattre
[Musique]
alors Valentine donc tu es journaliste
et youtubeuse oui mais toi qui es-tu
Nicolas Martel c'est vrai on m'a pas
présenté Nordine
Nicolas Martel et journaliste pour le
magazine Géo Ado s'il avait été à son
bureau vous l'auriez vu travailler sur
une enquête ou un reportage qu'il
signerait de son nom il a par exemple
réalisé des dossiers sur les sorcières
sur Mars la réalité virtuelle ou les
super-héros et ils présentent aussi la
cuisine de l'info et gare à perfeix sur
info ou MiTo la chaîne d'esprit critique
pour les ados produite parmi en presse
l'éditeur de geoado c'est Nicolas Martel
[Musique]
dernièrement tu as réalisé pour notre
chaîne info MiTo une vidéo sur les
pratiques louches de l'industrie du
tabac intitulé cigarette un complot
fumeux et si les cigarettiers avaient
manipulé les politiques les
scientifiques et l'opinion publique pour
faire du flouze en tuant des millions de
gens au passage complot comment tu as
travaillé sur ce thème très mal
j'ai travaillé alors tout d'abord on a
choisi le sujet ensemble enfin quand je
dis on c'est vous qui me l'avez proposé
et du coup on l'a fait ensemble et
c'était très chouette parce que
d'habitude on traitait plus des théories
du complot genre les pyramides ont été
construites par des extraterrestres tout
ça et vous vouliez pour une fois mettre
un vrai complot pour dire que les
complots ça existe pour changer et du
coup l'industrie du tabac et je me suis
dit banco allons-y c'est vachement bien
et donc j'ai commencé par un travail que
je trouve très journalistique finalement
tu me diras après si si tu es amené à
faire ce genre de travail aussi donc
d'abord j'ai défricher le sujet grâce à
internet donc je me suis basée sur des
articles de presse donc des grands
médias comme le monde libération tous
ces trucs là Wikipédia évidemment très
important
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
tellement documenté que enfin tout le
monde en parle donc c'est assez bien
j'ai aussi trouvé un rapport de l'OMS
donc c'est un rapport qui est construit
par une institution qui émane des
Nations Unies donc il y a pas plus
officielle que ça c'est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé merci qui donc qui
fait vraiment un rapport sur le complot
de l'industrie du tabac même aujourd'hui
parce que ça continue encore aujourd'hui
donc pour vous dire que côté source
j'avais absolument tout ce qu'il fallait
donc c'était très bien parfois aussi je
fais appel à des experts donc des
scientifiques par exemple des gens qui
s'y connaissent sur le sujet là en
l'occurrence j'avais déjà tout ce qu'il
fallait donc j'avais pas besoin et donc
à la suite de ça j'ai écrit l'article à
partir de toutes ces sources donc
j'arrive à un moment où je connais assez
bien sujet pour me dire allez je vais
écrire dessus et donc à ce moment-là je
me mets à écrire un script que je trouve
très alarmiste parce que c'est un sujet
qui est vraiment pas drôle c'est des
gens qui meurent c'est la première cause
de mort évitable dans le monde donc
vraiment c'était pas fan du tout et
j'essaye de faire des vidéos
relativement fun donc là j'ai essayé de
trouver un angle donc une façon de
raconter l'histoire qui était plus fun
et donc on a tourné ça sous forme de jeu
en fait donc
vous incarnez finalement un grand
méchant du tabac et vous vous essayez de
trouver toutes les tactiques pour
essayer de faire du profit en dépit
enfin au détriment de la santé des gens
et donc on a fait un script comme ça en
forme de jeu un petit peu ce qui fait
que les infos passent c'est moins
déprimant que ce que ce serait sinon
même si les infos en soi sont
extrêmement déprimantes et donc suite à
ça je vous ai envoyé le script pour
lecture donc vous avez pu relire valider
rajouter des petites choses des petites
indications parce que vous connaissez
bien ce sujet donc c'était assez
pratique et c'est ce qu'on fait
d'habitude d'ailleurs et donc après ça
c'est parti au tournage donc avec un
costume parce que c'est ma petite
tradition tournage montage et après je
vous ai renvoyé la vidéo à nouveau pour
validation vous avez validé vous l'avez
mise en ligne et puis voilà tout à fait
est-ce que c'est une approche que toi tu
retrouves dans ton travail de
journaliste complètement en fait c'est
ce que j'allais dire le toute la
première partie de ce que tu décris
c'est totalement un travail
journalistique alors tous les
journalistes vont pas ensuite se mettre
en scène il y a des médias dans lequel
on le fait mais traditionnellement on
reste plutôt sobre mais toute la
première partie
de du fait de rechercher des sources de
les recouper de construire finalement
une documentation et de l'explicité à un
public ça c'est complètement
journalistique
et on va passer un petit extrait
d'ailleurs de cette vidéo où tu nous
parles de fausses instituts de santé qui
ont été créés par ces industries du
tabac
une vingtaine d'années que votre
entreprise prospère yup la boum les
chercheurs commencent à faire un lien
entre la cigarette et le cancer coup dur
mais vous riposter aussitôt merci du
tuyau on va se pencher sur la question
et là vous créez carrément votre propre
institut de recherche appelez-le le
conseil de recherche sur le tabac
l'Institut du tabac ou le centre de
recherche sur l'air intérieur les gens
n'y verront que du feu servez-vous-en
pour financer des recherches un peu
partout même en France évidemment vous
publiez de la science bidon ne
communiquez que les résultats qui vont
dans votre sens ou alors des résultats
un peu flous qui suggèrent qu'on peut
pas conclure le but c'est vraiment de
noyer le poisson il faut que les gens
pensent que finalement on sait pas
vraiment si la cigarette est dangereuse
pour la santé votre fond de commerce
c'est le doute il tiendra 40 ans avant
d'être dissous votre centre de recherche
bidon le Wall Street Journal la même
jugé responsable de la plus longue
campagne de désinformation de l'histoire
économique des États-Unis mais elle
exploie c'est un faux par exemple
comment tu sais quel est vrai et bien je
sais qu'elle est vraie parce que je j'ai
ce qu'on appelle en journaliste croiser
mes sources c'est à dire que j'ai trouvé
la même information à plein d'endroits
différents sur des endroits le donc des
endroits qui qui sont solides donc à la
fois l'OMS dont on parlait il y avait
l'info sur Wikipédia il y avait l'info
qui était reprise par plein de
journalistes aussi dans des études qui
parlaient de ça donc voilà c'est à
partir du moment où plein de gens
parlent de la chose sous la même version
c'est que il y a de fortes chances que
ce soit vrai d'accord d'ailleurs
justement il y a une classe du collège
de Montguyon en Charente-Maritime qu'on
salue au passage qui nous pose cette
question quelle est la fiabilité des
informations qu'on trouve sur Youtube
comment on fait pour vérifier les infos
ça tu viens un petit peu d'expliquer
mais surtout quels conseils on peut leur
donner pour qu'il soit sûr eux que les
informations qui le regardent soient
fiable et ben ça c'est une grande
question parce qu'effectivement sur
Youtube on trouve de tout parce que tout
le monde peut ouvrir une chaîne Youtube
et donc effectivement on peut trouver
absolument tout y compris des contenus
complotistes des contenus au contraire
de médias enfin il y a il y a vraiment
de tout et donc c'est bien d'avoir en
tête des petits outils qui peuvent nous
aider à faire la différence entre le
vrai et le faux et donc notamment j'en
ai fait une petite liste donc on peut
regarder si les vidéastes affichent
leurs sources en description de la vidéo
en général on peut développer la
description et en général on peut voir
source de points avec un lien et donc si
on clique sur le lien on peut voir
est-ce que le vidéaste indique ses
sources premier point et ce que les
sources sont de qualité donc ce dont je
parlais donc si ça vient de média ça
vient de Wikipédia si ça vient d'étude
scientifiques dans le cas de de contenu
scientifique ça c'est top si après vous
voyez des liens un peu et ben posez-vous
des questions un autre truc important
vous pouvez regarder les commentaires
comment les gens réagissent à la vidéo
donc ça c'est pour des sujets qui sont
pas trop polémiques donc des trucs un
peu tranquille sur comment fonctionne la
photosynthèse par exemple si vous avez
des commentaires qui encensent la
personne donc qui disent ouais c'est
vachement bien vous pouvez vous dire bon
ça va ça paraît assez correct si au
contraire il y a des gens qui soulignent
des erreurs dans la vidéo regardez
comment réagit le créateur de la vidéo
donc est-ce qu'il va juste passer ça
sous le tapis est-ce qu'au contraire il
va prendre ça en compte faire un petit
erratum on dit donc une petite
correction en commentaire de la vidéo
par exemple ou sur les réseaux sociaux
donc ça c'est important de voir comment
lui-même réagit quand on le signale une
erreur et c'est important de le dire les
c'est vrai aussi des médias
traditionnels des médias écrits par
exemple les journalistes qui travaillent
pour ces médias sont des êtres humains
peuvent faire des erreurs ce qui
différencie un média honnête d'autres
médias c'est qu'on reconnaisse ses
erreurs que si une erreur est manifeste
on publie un narum pour expliquer où on
s'est trompé voilà il y a un autre point
aussi pour les vidéos donc là c'est plus
les vidéos controversées
ées la zone 51 enfin voilà les pyramides
tous ces trucs là vous pouvez avoir un
bandeau YouTube donc c'est Youtube qui
affiche lui-même en disant attention
c'est un sujet qui est un peu tendu
allez lire cette page Wikipédia qui en
parle très bien pour savoir si vous êtes
tombé sur une vidéo complotiste ou pas
donc si vous allez sur les vidéos de
info MiTo je pense que toutes les vidéos
on le fameux bandeau parce que on parle
toujours de sujet un peu tendus
et donc toi tu as fait une vidéo sur le
changement climatique récemment oui
c'est vrai pour info exactement
mais selon un rapport de l'OCDE paru en
juillet dernier la France compte encore
de nombreuses personnes qui soient ne
croient pas au réchauffement climatique
soit son très mal informés sur ces
causes et ses effets et quand on a une
population qui ne comprend pas ou ne
veut pas comprendre l'urgence de la
situation c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de prendre des décisions pour résoudre
le problème alors ça n'empêche pas le
débat faut-il plutôt économiser
l'énergie développer à fond les
renouvelables relancer le nucléaire ou
tout ça à la fois ça peut se discuter
mais même si on n'est pas tous d'accord
sur les solutions à apporter aux
problèmes faudrait au moins se mettre
d'accord sur le fait que ce problème là
il existe
or ceux qui instit le doute donnent aux
citoyens et aux politiques des raisons
de ne pas agir et ça c'est un gros
danger parce que pour les scientifiques
il y a pas photo un le réchauffement
climatique est un phénomène réel et
observable de il est dû aux activités
humaines qui rejettent d'énormes
quantités de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère 3 il menace notre mode de
vie et à terme la survie de nombreuses
espèces végétales et animales et enfin 4
ces conséquences sont déjà plus
importantes que celle qui est envisagée
il y a quelques années
quel merveilleuse vidéo merci et donc
quel talent donc
les changements climatiques c'est quand
même un sujet qui est assez tendu aussi
comment tu fais pour justement faire le
tri dans les sources et pas dire des
bêtises alors déjà moi je suis
journaliste je suis pas journaliste
scientifique j'ai pas de formation
scientifique à la base il y a des
journées qui en ont c'est pas mon cas
mais en tant que journaliste on se
repose sur quelque chose qui s'appelle
le consensus scientifique on sait que
certains sujets sont traités par des
dizaines de milliers de chercheurs dans
le monde en ce qui concerne le climat il
y a un groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts sur l'évolution du climat le
GIEC qui publie depuis des années des
rapports qui sont en fait des synthèses
d'études qui ont lieu partout dans le
monde qui vont dans un seul sens c'est
que le réchauffement climatique bah il
existe c'est indéniable et que sont le
facteur premier du réchauffement
climatique ce sont les activités
humaines et ça c'est un consensus
scientifique ça veut dire que en gros la
communauté scientifique est d'accord
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus proche d'un
fait qu'on ne peut pas contester on peut
trouver des gens isolés qui vont dire
ouais je suis pas d'accord c'est pas la
faute des humains c'est à cause des du
soleil qui a des cycles
mais c'est pas parce que une personne
dit ça qu'il faut le mettre à équivalent
de ce que dit le GIAC non il y a le
consensus scientifique qui est beaucoup
plus crédible parce qu'il regroupe les
paroles d'experts de centaines de
milliers d'experts partout dans le monde
qui se valident les uns les autres en
fait qui vérifie que chacun dit quelque
chose de correct parce que la science
est un processus collectif et correctif
bon donc on vient de décrire qu'en fait
on fait le même métier on fait la même
chose mais sur Youtube on trouve aussi
des contenus qui sont beaucoup moins
sérieux qui sont plus de l'ordre du
divertissement ouais
je t'en prie tu peux élaborer non comme
ça oui alors effectivement sur Youtube
en gros il y a deux grandes tendances il
y en a plein d'autres parce qu'il y a la
musique aussi enfin bref dans ce qu'on
voit il y a de grandes tendances c'est
le l'information et le divertissement il
y a ceux qui sont là pour rigoler et
faire rigoler c'est très bien et il y a
ceux qui sont là pour informer et faire
passer des informations sérieuses on
peut aussi faire passer des informations
sérieuses en rigolant je pense être bien
passé pour le dire enfin faire rigoler
et rigoler moi je rigole beaucoup dans
mes vidéos des fois ça fait rire les
gens pas tout le temps mais bref c'est
gênant
je me suis perdue dans ce que je voulais
dire oui donc il y a l'information et le
divertissement et effectivement dans
l'information il y a des gens qui ne
sont pas journalistes à la base mais qui
font quand même un super boulot et
d'ailleurs c'est rigolo parce que j'ai
un ami qui est aussi journaliste de
formation et youtubeurs et on s'est
rendu compte à quel point les
vulgarisateurs en tout cas donc ceux qui
font de la science sur Youtube enfin
vulgarisation scientifique du coup ont
une approche qui est justement très
journalistique et ils s'en rendent pas
compte c'est vraiment lui et moi on s'en
est rendu compte donc c'est vraiment
très très similaire et il y en a aussi
qui font pas dans la science mais qui
font du journalisme sur Youtube sans
cette journaliste à la base donc je
pense à Hugo décrypte à Gaspard j'ai
tout ça et Hugo décret qui a d'ailleurs
monté son média donc il était sur
Youtube avant d'être journaliste
techniquement même si il faisait déjà du
journaliste à la base c'est pas très
clair ce que je viens de dire c'est pas
moi je trouve ça très clair ok tant
mieux
mais ouais du coup en fait ce qui est
intéressant là c'est la méthode
du coup ce qui est intéressant là c'est
leur méthode en fait quand on prend Hugo
décrypte Gaspard g ils ont une méthode
de travail qui est très journalistique
ou qui vérifie les sources les sources
sont accessibles il relayent
l'information il donne pas spécialement
d'avis il relay l'information donc ça
c'est vraiment à ça qu'on reconnaît les
journalistes je trouve oui c'est
effectivement ça ressemble exactement au
métier que que moi j'ai toujours fait
même si maintenant je suis sur Youtube
mais j'ai jamais pensé être devenu un
youtubeur parce que moi je travaille à
gwado donc les trois quarts du temps je
suis dans ma rédaction je travaille je
fais des articles pour un média écrit et
de temps en temps je sors de ma
rédaction et je viens parler dans cette
caméra est-ce que tu as trouvé que
l'approche était différente quand tu es
passé l'un à l'autre ou pas adapter
alors j'ai pas dû m'adapter sur la façon
dont je travaille parce que finalement
que j'écrive un article ou que je tourne
une vidéo je vais quand même écrire un
texte en mode documentant en croisant
les sources parfois un interrogeant un
expert exactement comme tu l'as décrit
c'est la forme qui change c'est des
médias différents donc déjà on va se
permettre plus de blagues sur Youtube on
a un ton un peu plus léger quoi qu'en
presse jeunesse c'est pas non plus comme
comme un journal comme un journal de
référence comme le monde voilà on va se
permettre de parler à nos lecteurs un
peu plus directement de façon un peu
plus familiale
exactement on va dire je alors c'est pas
très journalistique paraît-il mais nous
on le fait beaucoup et sur Youtube on le
fait énormément on se met en avant et
donc c'est ça moi j'ai dû m'adapter
parce que j'ai dû apprendre à parler
devant une caméra sans bugger par
exemple
certains n'y arrivent encore pas très
très bien donc il y a effectivement le
jeu et puis aussi l'approche qui est
très différente quand je disais je
mettais des costumes dans mes vidéos ça
c'est pas le genre de truc que je
pourrais faire en tant que journaliste
dans une rédaction normale je pense là
c'est vraiment parce que vous êtes
jeunesse parce que vous me laissez une
carte blanche pour faire absolument tout
ce que je veux toutes les bêtises du
monde et c'est hyper agréable mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a une approche très très
différente je trouve de ce point de vue
là mais uniquement dans la forme donc
dans la façon de parler de raconter
l'information mais pas dans le sérieux
de l'information pour autant c'est pour
ça qu'on dit venu te chercher justement
alors on a une nouvelle question
intéressante cette fois-ci la question
vient de la classe de 6e 6 du collège
Théodore Monod à Margencel en
Haute-Savoie
je salue les marges en ces lois j'ai pas
commencé j'ai de la famille à Margencel
ouais salut et Augustin
très pertinente combien d'argent vous
gagnez plein beaucoup trop beaucoup vous
en voulez tu es sérieuse non non je
gagne ce qu'il faut pour vivre déjà j'ai
envie donc c'est hyper cool parce que
c'est rare de pouvoir en vivre sur
Youtube en général on a l'impression de
voir des youtubeurs stars et de se dire
waouh c'est vachement facile comme
métier on gagne vachement d'argent mais
en fait il y en a très très peu qui
deviennent des stars il y en a
moyennement qui arrivent à en vivre
comme moi et il y en a énormément qui
ont échoué en fait qui ont jamais réussi
à en vivre et qui ont commencé à faire
ça à côté de leur boulot ou à côté de
leurs études ou ce que vous voulez et ça
a jamais décollé donc ils ont jamais pu
faire ça donc en fait ce qu'on appelle
le biais du survivant on envoie un cas
réussi on se dit ah c'est facile mais en
fait on voit pas tous ceux qui ont
échoué derrière donc ouais il y a ça à
prendre en compte quand même et toi tu
gagnes combien suffisamment pour vivre
pareil mais moi j'ai une grosse
différence c'est que je suis salarié
d'un un groupe de presse donc 1000 ans
presse qui appartient à Bayard je reçois
le même salaire tous les mois
c'est à dire que ma vidéo quand je fais
des vidéos YouTube elle peut faire 30
vues ou 300000 vues je serai payé pareil
à la fin voilà il y a pas d'incidence je
suis pas salarié de YouTube s'il y a des
publicités sur ma sur mes vidéos je
touche rien dessus parce que en fait
comment ça se passe comment on se
finance quels sont les sources de
revenus différentes pour un youtubeurs
il y en a plusieurs ouais il y en a
plusieurs alors ta cité la publicité on
pense toujours que qu'on peut gagner 3
millions d'euros avec une vidéo c'est
pas le cas peut-être quand vous êtes
très très célèbre mais en général la pub
ça rapporte très très peu j'ai des
chiffres là que j'ai noté vite fait
imaginons que vous faites une vidéo avec
100000 vues c'est énorme même moi
j'attends pas 100000 vues sur toutes mes
vidéos vous avez gagné entre on va dire
80 et 200 euros de avec la publicité
donc vous savez les publicités qui sont
soit avant soit pendant soit après soit
tout ça avec votre vidéo donc en fait
c'est vraiment rien c'est très très peu
il y a d'autres sources de financement
donc il y a les plateformes de
financement participatif je sais pas
trop comment on dit mais en gros les
tips si vous connaissez un peu il y a
des sites en particulier ou des gens
peuvent dire ah j'aime bien ce que ce
qu'elle fait elle je lui ai donné un
euro par mois par exemple donc c'est des
gens comme vous et moi qui donnaient de
l'argent donc il y a ça il y a aussi les
finances les financements publics n'ont
dé subventions notamment du centre de
cinéma Centre national du cinéma animé
je crois donc il y a quelques
subventions de l'argent public et on a
aussi et surtout le truc dont on parle
c'est les partenariats avec des marques
qui peuvent prendre la forme de soit une
vidéo dédiée comme j'ai pu faire
récemment avec une marque de papier
toilette ils m'ont contacté en disant
bonjour on fait une vidéo ensemble
j'aurais dit mais oui du papier toilette
on fait une vidéo ils étaient super bien
et aussi des ce qu'on appelle des sponso
donc là c'est une marque qui vous
contacte pour dire je vais je voudrais
que tu parles de mon produit pendant
donc par exemple de mon VPN si vous
allez sur Internet bref et donc tu vas
parler de mon VPN dans ta vidéo pendant
une à deux minutes donc soit au milieu
soit au début soit à la fin encore et là
pour le coup c'est moi qui écrit la pub
c'est moi qui la tourne c'est moi qui
m'aime à touche dedans et tout mais
surtout ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas
d'influence sur le contenu de la vidéo
je préfère une vidéo sur les minéraux et
parler de VPN pendant une minute ou deux
ça les dérange pas de connexion ouais
donc ça c'est quand même cool je trouve
finalement c'est pas très éloigné des
publicités qu'on a dans les magazines on
a une page de pub qui est payé par un
annonceur extérieur
alors on a une régie pub qui choisit qui
qui peut passer des publicités dans nos
magazines on va on a on est comme un
magazine jeunesse donc on va pas laisser
n'importe qui non plus mettre son
contenu et puis on a aussi des
partenariats c'est à dire que parfois on
va faire un accord avec
une institution extérieure moi je pense
à quelque chose de qui m'est arrivé je
suis parti en reportage au Liban avec un
camp de réfugiés syrien avec une ONG qui
s'appelle Handicap International donc il
y a un rapport financier puisque c'est
eux qui ont payé mon voyage en gros
et puis j'ai parlé de leur travail sur
place mais en même temps on savait que
c'était des gens de confiance qui
faisaient un travail important on avait
envie d'en parler donc finalement tout
le monde était gagnant et on n'a pas de
problème éthique à travailler avec ce
type de partenaire oui c'est ça le tout
c'est de choisir ses part et de pas
bosser pour n'importe qui de la même
manière moi j'ai bossé avec le Muséum
national d'Histoire naturelle de Paris
donc c'est vachement cool et pareil
c'était pour promouvoir un de leurs
programmes de sciences participative
donc en gros les gens se baladent dans
la dans la rue ou dans la campagne il
voit des cailloux ils peuvent les
renseigner sur un site et après les
chercheurs se servent de toutes ces
informations pour faire de la science
avec donc c'est hyper cool ouais c'est
super chouette et j'étais très contente
d'en parler donc voilà il y a pas que du
papier toilette dans la vie il y a aussi
des cailloux il y a aussi des cailloux
et oui parce qu'il fallait la différence
aussi entre votre manière de travailler
en tant que youtubeur et la nôtre en
tant que journaliste dans des dans des
médias plus tradis c'est que nous on a
des rédactions on est on est plusieurs
on est des équipes vous vous faites un
peu tout vous faites un peu vous êtes un
peu des humains orchestre en fait ouais
exactement alors moi pour les très gros
youtubeurs qui ont carrément une société
avec ils embauchent des gens qui se
servent par exemple de d'agents pour se
servir de justement de faire tout ce qui
est pub et partenariat et tout ça ils
peuvent avoir des auteurs des monteurs
des cadres enfin toute une équipe pour
les aider à faire du boulot et au
finalement ils sont juste présentateurs
mais quand on est petit ou moyen
effectivement on peut être amené à tout
faire soi-même moi je fais tout moi-même
et comment on acquiert ces compétences
là sur le tas on discute entre nous il y
en a qui savent et du coup ils
apprennent aux autres et puis voilà
c'est chouette ok c'est chouette vous
avez des partenariats des publicités
exactement comme nous il y a pas plus de
risques de conflits d'intérêt finalement
avec des youtubeurs qu'avec des journées
classiques oui oui non c'est la même
chose effectivement il faut choisir ses
partenariats faut faire attention à
pas faire de la pub à n'importe qui il
faut faire un peu du background check
comme on dit donc vérifier que que
l'entreprise dont on va parler fait pas
des trucs horribles par derrière voilà
c'est ça il faut faire attention après
on peut avoir des mauvaises surprises
des trucs qui sortent après mais bon
voilà après à partir du moment le
contrat est terminé enfin voilà on peut
s'autoriser des choses par exemple j'ai
fait la pub d'un site de poster qui fait
des posters et en même temps leur
argument marketing c'était qui plantait
un arbre pour chaque poster à acheter un
truc comme ça j'ai fait une vidéo après
plus tard pour raconter à quel point le
fait de planter des arbres pour sauver
la planète en fait c'était des bêtises
c'était juste un argument marketing et
en fait ça sert à rien si tu
greenwashing et donc là évidemment je
les ai cités parce que j'ai pas résisté
mais je bosserai plus avec eux je pense
non c'est terminé mais ça valait le coup
je ne regrette rien donc en fait conflit
d'intérêt oui ou non on peut s'autoriser
ce qu'on veut faut pas faut pas se
censurer soi-même quoi c'est peut-être
plus vrai sur d'autres médias parce
qu'on parle beaucoup des influenceurs
qui ne cite pas forcément les gens qui
les payent pour dire du bien de tel ou
tel produit ouais c'est ça j'ai
l'impression que c'est encore plus flou
sur Instagram et sur Tik Tok par exemple
mais sur Youtube c'est quand même
relativement bien installé maintenant et
donc on sait notamment qu'il faut cocher
la petite case partenariat rémunérée ce
qui fait que quand vous commencez une
vidéo ça s'affiche YouTube affiche un
petit truc en haut cette vidéo enfin
votre vidéaste a été payé pour parler
d'un truc dans la vidéo on annonce la
couleur
on arrive à la fin de ce webinaire donc
on va faire un petit résumé de ce qu'on
s'est dit d'accord donc là c'est le
moment où tu mannes planes que j'ai dit
c'est le moment où je le résume
alors tout d'abord sur la fiabilité des
informations qui sont données sur
Youtube et ben il suffit de regarder les
sources c'est elle qui permet de
déterminer si on a fait un travail
sérieux si les sources ne sont pas
donnés
si c'est pas top méfiez-vous
ensuite sur les méthodes de travail en
fait c'est les mêmes qu'on soit
journaliste
égaré sur Youtube ou youtuber qui fait
du journalisme on travaille de la même
façon on va chercher des sources fiables
on va interroger les experts parfois on
va recouper nos informations
la petite différence c'est que nous on
travaille plus en équipe on a plus on a
la chance d'avoir plus de personnes sur
un pour travailler sur un sujet que vous
qui êtes un peu un peu désamorcestre on
a dit et nous de notre côté on a plus de
liberté éditoriale donc sur ce qu'on
peut dire et la forme dont on peut le
dire même s'il y a des exceptions des
deux côtés c'est vrai ensuite la grosse
différence qui va y avoir ce mode de
rémunération moi je suis salarié d'un
groupe de presse moi je dépends de plein
de choses donc j'ai à côté des vidéos en
plus je fais d'autres trucs qui me
rapportent aussi des revenus donc en
fait c'est une somme de plein de revenus
et j'ai pas un salaire fixe chaque mois
donc c'est ça aussi et c'est ça qui
m'incite aussi à vouloir faire grandir
la chaîne parce que c'est à partir d'un
certain seuil on peut commencer à
intéresser les annonceurs pour faire des
sponsors on peut choper des subventions
enfin voilà ce genre de choses
et enfin les conflits d'intérêts ça
existe ça peut exister aussi bien dans
le journalisme traditionnel que sur
Youtube
l'important c'est d'afficher ce qu'on
fait quand on fait de la publicité de le
dire quand on a un partenariat de le
dire et puis il faut aussi être
conscient que on a souvent des
partenariats mais qu'on choisit avec qui
on les fait on va pas travailler avec
des gens dont on partage pas l'éthique
ou les valeurs et puis le l'option que
je trouve la mieux c'est quand même la
sponso dans le sens où la sponso
n'aurait pas de rapport avec le contenu
de la vidéo comme ça on est sûr qu'il y
a pas d'influence de l'un sur l'autre
c'est je trouve c'est le mieux c'est pas
mal
voilà donc on arrive à la fin de ce
webinaire merci pour votre écoute
n'hésitez pas à retourner sur la chaîne
info ou MiTo ou webinar va être en
replay d'ici quelques minutes
nous allons nous retrouver d'ici
quelques mois dans cette donc pour un
prochain webinaire en attendant
n'hésitez pas à lâcher un petit pouce en
l'air un abonnement et d'ici là gardez
l'esprit critique